[Musik]
herzlich willkommen so salis wels wir
waren wieder mit meinem gesamten team on
tour und zwar dieses mal in freiburg auf
der baden messe dh wir sind unserem
partnerland treu geblieben und waren im
heimischen gebiet ja auf der badenmesse
waren wir zwei tage und die daten müsse
dies auch wirklich sehr interessant da
geht es ganz ganz viel zu sehen und da
waren wir samstag und sonntag und haben
unseren eigenen stand aufgebaut auf der
messe habe ich wie üblich gebacken und
gekocht und meine zuschauer haben uns
besucht sie durften wir wieder fragen
stellen haben ganz viel kuchen und
leckeres essen probiert und natürlich
haben wir auch in der autogrammstunde
fleißig fotos gemacht und autogramme
geschrieben bücher signiert und so
weiter frau wirklich wieder eine richtig
schöne messe und was ich immer ganz toll
finde wenn unser freund jahr sind mit
kommt der dann immer auch mit mir
zusammen 1 show macht er unterstützt
mich dabei und macht zum beispiel auch
hypnose was wirklich alle menschen total
begeistert also selbst heute noch denke
ich immer menschen funktioniert in
hypnose überhaupt aber er hat es wieder
geschafft alle in seinen bann zu ziehen
und wieder eine richtig tolle
performance hinzulegen
natürlich war auch unser onlineshop
wieder mit dabei wo es eben unsere
produkte gibt mein gesamtes team war
dabei und wir hatten auch wieder berater
von kitchenaid und kam und dabei einmal
der christian dass ich am kenwood
kümmert und der benni der sich um
kitchenaid kümmert und beide sind
natürlich auch immer mit vor ort und
beraten euch ganz gerne wenn es um das
thema küchenmaschinen geht ja auf der
messe gab es dieses mal ein ganz ganz
besonderes highlight denn wir haben zwei
dinge vorgestellt zum einen mein neues
buch mein drittes werk und zwar heißt
dieses sally & friends das ist ein
rezeptbuch mit einfachen rezepten für
kinder aber auch erwachsene und das ist
einfach ein ganz tolles charity projekt
von dem wir wahrscheinlich schon gehört
habt in diesem zuge haben wir auch ein
kinderlied vorgestellt und zwar hat uns
der matte kontaktiert matti ist ein
kinderliedermacher und hat gesagt mensch
sally ich finde eure aktionen mit oskar
dem sorgentelefon so toll ich möchte
euch gerne unterstützen
und er hat dann und lied für uns
geschrieben und vergaben mit und
ich habe ein bisschen mitgewirkt aber
ich habe nichts gesungen keine sorge
singen kann ich nämlich nicht aber ich
habe ein bisschen sprechgesang was
irgendwie sprechgesang ja so ein
bisschen was schon sprechgesang habe ich
doch mit einfließen lassen und ich bin
euch jetzt mal das lied ab und in der
zeit kennt ihr noch ein paar schöne
bilder von der messe sehen
[Musik]
immer wieder sehe ich
menschen die sind nicht glücklich sie
sind böse wütend und traurig man sieht
genau in ihrem gesicht
böse menschen schauen meist nicht so als
wenn sie in ihrem
neben noch nie froh
für den menschen schauen müssen
jetzt müssten sie ganz dringend auf das
klo
wenn jemand traurig ist dann schaut er
sei
und das macht mich überhaupt nicht vor
[Musik]
ja ich backe backe backe backe kuchen
voller glück und du und durch und durch
ihr bekommt davon ein stück
der bösewicht traurig das mag ich
überhaupt nicht darum nimmt ein großes
stück vom kuchen voller glück
zwei esslöffel
voll freude
ein hund vom spaß
50 gramm
von der fröhlichkeit
und eine ganz große krise vor
dankbarkeit
backe backe backe kuchen
und du
und das stück der böse
trauring das mag ich überhaupt nicht
warum ein großes stück vom kuchen voller
glück
alle schaut mal
[Musik]
so sieht es aus wenn alle glücklich sind
ja ich denke backen gebackenen kuchen
nein
kommt dann ein stück der böse mit dem
traurig
mag ich überhaupt nicht
ein großes stück von meinem
kundenfreundlich
marcelo und friends buch gekauft und du
weißt was damit passiert das mit dem
hospiz auch mit oscars telefon
wie findest du das projekt und hast du
schon das buch angeschaut wie findest du
das buch ich habe kurz reingeschaut weiß
kann eben gekauft habe und ich finde es
toll vor allen dingen so ich gelesen
habe jedes jahr 100 prozent der erlös
dorthin
ich finde es nämlich wichtig gerade
gesundheit dass da die menschen
unterstützt werden und dass sie die tat
so viel dafür tut und ich finde das auto
das man durch diesen kauf dieses projekt
unterstützen kann
ich finde das projekt toll also mir
gefällt das projekt das das sah
gespendet wird
wie findest du das buch cool
ja ich finde es gut und ich die rezepte
gefalle mir alle und ich finde es auch
gut amélie der ganze erlös spendet ich
finde sie macht sehr gut und ich finde
es auch ein zirkusprojekt dass sie das
mit dem sorgenkind macht ja natürlich
sehr interessant und auch wichtig dass
man solche sachen unterstützt und damit
macht dann auch ich finde das projekt
richtig koloniales buch kaufen
also ich habe mir das buch gekauft und
das ist der hammer ich habe im vorfeld
schon ein paar der rezepte bekommen habe
sie nachgebaut und meine familie ist
durchgedreht die wollte man die zugabe
haben und jetzt werde ich mir gleich ein
paar davon kaufen und wäre es ja ein
paar tollen menschen schenken weil ich
das projekt toll finde oscars telefon
sowieso aber auch dass mit dem hospiz
einfach eine tolle geschichte
und hier auf der messe sind so viele die
das buch kaufen und ich finde es sollte
jeder kaufen denn das wird zu 100
prozent gespendet leute kauft euch
dieses buch hier
ja und größtenteils ging es natürlich um
diese buchvorstellung um sally and
friends einfache rezepte für jeden tag
und dieses buch entstand einfach kurz
vor unserem sommerurlaub da wurde ich
nämlich auf die aktion oft gerade
sorgentelefon aufmerksam und zwar ist
das sorgentelefon es wurde gegründet vom
bundesverband kinderhospiz und da geht
es einfach darum es gibt einfach viel zu
wenig kinderhospize in deutschland und
es gibt aber 40.000 unheilbar kranke
kinder
das heißt deswegen wurde oscar ins leben
gerufen das sorgentelefon
das könnt ihr euch so vorstellen da
arbeiten rund um die uhr seelsorger
psychologen oder auch betreuer und da
können sich wirklich familien dran
wenden oder auch betroffene freunde
lehrer eltern und so weiter und da kann
jeder und kinder natürlich auch und da
kann man jederzeit anrufen und einfach
fragen stellen oder sie können zb auch
beratend zur seite stehen und einfach
sagen wo oder ein wenig institutionen
ihr euch wenden müsste und das finde ich
einfach eine ganz tolle sache und oft da
wird einfach finanziert durch spenden
und deswegen habe ich auch dieses buch
gemacht und hab gedacht mensch so kann
ich einfach meinen teil dazu beisteuern
hab ich hier ganz viele tolle rezepte
mit dabei und der gesamte gewinn geht
eben an oskar das sorgentelefon ganz
alleine habe ich das buch natürlich
nicht gemacht ich hatte es tatkräftige
unterstützung von meinem team die
wirklich tage nach mit mir in der küche
standen gekocht und gebacken haben
rezepte fotografiert haben
und natürlich hätte ich das auch niemals
ohne den verlag geschafft und zwar ist
der pax verlags und da hat der christoph
das ist ein ganz lieber freund von uns
uns wirklich unterstützt ich habe eben
die rezepte und die fotos zukommen
lassen und er hat es dann mit seinem
team gemeinsam gestaltet und es war
wirklich ein ganz enger zusammenarbeit
und ich muss sagen es hat wirklich alles
super geklappt also ich bin mit dem buch
sehr zufrieden ist es wirklich ganz toll
geworden und ihr müsst nicht so ein
bisschen auf entdeckungstour gehen denn
während dem produktionsprozessen und so
viele tolle ideen gekommen
wir haben verhindert gründe gemalt oder
auch zum beispiel die drei affen hier
drücken wir mal hier sind ganz viele
tolle geschichten mit dabei auch von
zuschauern die ihre rezepte eingeschickt
haben und ein paar davon habe ich
einfach ausgewählt
und hiermit reingepackt die lieben
zuschauer natürlich und ein rezept ist
auch von murat dabei und zwar ist es das
saure murat den müsst ihr auf jeden fall
mal entdecken das ist ja auch regional
schwäbisches rezept ja in diesem zuge
möchte ich mich auch ganz ganz herzlich
bei der facebook gruppe leckereien aus
tillichs welt verdanken
die haben nämlich aus eigener initiative
heraus einfach eine spendenaktion
gestartet und zwar waren das die fünf
administratoren der gruppe und die haben
einfach den spendenaufruf gemacht und
haben die stolze summe von 3350 euro
zusammenbekommen
ich glaube insgesamt waren es 262
spender und es war wirklich so dass
wirklich jeder einfach was gespendet hat
das war noch ganz kleine beträge dabei
wirklich von menschen die auch gar nicht
so viel haben aber trotzdem ganz ganz
viele geben ganz beeindruckt hat mich
auch die kleine anna zum beispiel die
hatte ihr komplettes taschengeld
gespendet und sie hat mich auch auf der
messe besucht und liebe anna ich fand
das so toll von dir
es haben menschen auf urlaub verzichtet
um einfach auf das sorgentelefon
unterstützen zu können
und ich finde es einfach so selbstlos
von euch und wirklich ganz ganz toll
ich denke jeder kann sich einfach eine
scheibe von abschneiden und euch
wirklich auch als vorbild nehmen und man
sieht einfach dass man wirklich auch mit
kleinen dingen viel erreichen kann wenn
man einfach nur möchte ja die gruppe ist
wirklich richtig toll wir haben da schon
über 35.000 mitglieder also ich hatte
anfangs mit der gruppe gar nichts zu tun
ist dann wirklich die administratoren
ganz einfach selber gegründet und es ist
wirklich eine ganz tolle gruppe ganz
viel austausch und da könnt ihr gerne
mal vorbeischauen
ja was ich noch sagen möchte es habe
mich wieder ganz viele kinder auf der
messe besucht ganz viele kleine babys
mit denen ich dann natürlich ein
bisschen kuscheln muss immer da müssen
die anderen besucher ganz kurz immer
warten bis ich meine kuschel phase
beendet habe und das freut mich immer
noch sehr also wenn ihr babys und kinder
habt kommt auf jeden fall immer vorbei
ich habe immer zeit für euch und nehmen
wir auch gerne zeit für jeden ja das
buch gibt es heute ab 11 uhr in unserem
onlineshop also da steht es dann zum
verkauf bereit auf der messe war wie
gesagt ein freescale also da konnte man
sich das buch schon mal anschauen und
auch kaufen und das buch gibt es online
nur bei uns das heißt nur bei unseren
online shop und ich hab dann auch ganz
viele märkte supermärkte und so weiter
angeschrieben und gefragt mensch könnt
ihr uns unter
könnt ihr das buch bei euch im programm
aufnehmen damit aus gar das
sorgentelefon einfach finanziert werden
kann
und ich muss euch sagen es war nur der
globus-markt dabei der dann innerhalb
von zehn minuten gesagt hat sei live
unterstützen dich dabei das ist eine
ganz tolle aktion
die haben wirklich nur einmal ganz kurz
rücksprache gehalten und sofort haben
alle globus märkte das buch bestellt und
ab nächste woche donnerstag bekommt ihr
das buch also sozusagen auch in allen
globus märkten
da könnt ihr euch zum beispiel die
versandkosten sparen indem ihr einfach
dahin fahrt und das buch dort holt ja
finde ich echt eine ganz tolle aktion
fiel vielen dank an euch und wir hatten
auch ganz viele andere sponsoren und
firmen die uns unterstützt haben
zum einen haben wir zb die firma
fedrigoni die uns das papier zur
verfügung gestellt hat und die haben
auch ein ganz kleines video gemacht und
habe ich auch etwas zu sagen
grüßt euch ganz herzlich aus unserem
münchner showroom besucher begeistert
wir hier von oskar strom telefon wir
freuen uns
die beiden kinder kochbuch mit unserem
kapieren unterstützen zu können wird die
politik auf 125 jahre papiermacher
tradition zurück eine lange
erfolgsgeschichte auf die wir sehr stolz
sind und dann der abriss deutsche
projekt wie die ausgasungen telefon
unterstützen können über facebook seite
sind wir auch ein aufruf gestoßen
das schicksal so viele unheilbar kranken
kindern bewegt uns genauso wie auch
nicht und wir wollen dabei helfen das
leid dieser kinder und ihrer familien
zumindest ein bisschen zu lindern
vielen dank für eure wunderbare aktion
im euroland ist anders wir freuen uns
teil von zentis kinderkopf zu sein und
wünschen euch ganz viel erfolg für das 3
auch holger tours hat uns kontaktiert
und hat gefragt sally wie können welche
unterstützen und ich hab dann eben
direkt auf dieses buch hingewiesen und
auch die haben uns ein kleines video
geschickt hallo liebes mein name ist
sammelwerk rosetti und ich bin die
geschäftsführerin von öger tours dem
türkei-spezialisten einige meiner
kollegen sind riesen fans von dir und
deinen deutsch-türkischen kochkünsten
dass youtube bürger ist unser absoluter
favorit über youtube und instagram sind
wir oft dich und deine initiative mit
dem kinderhospiz aufmerksam geworden
bewundern deinen einsatz sehr und
möchten dich und die stiftung bei diesem
projekt aktiv unterstützen die
rezeptbücher und die idee dahinter
werden wir in unsere geschäftspartner
und reisebüros weitergeben
und ich bin mir sicher dass diese sich
bei der hilfsaktion beteiligen werden
wir hoffen sehr dass du viel erfolg
haben wirst und dass viele spendengelder
für das projekt zusammen kommen und man
somit den kindern viele wünsche erfüllen
kann
wir wünschen euch viel erfolg bei der
aktion und werden euch weiterhin aktiv
unterstützen
auch die firma stabiler hat sich
eingebracht und ich hab dir auch schon
auf der messe vorgestellt stabiler kennt
ihr wahrscheinlich alle auch wenn euch
der name ist vielleicht nichts sagt aber
ihr kennt auf jeden fall alle die
wasserwagen die gelben morath ab und so
auch so ein käppi auf sieht auch ganz
cool aus und es ist auch die firma hat
die uns zum beispiel die sally meter
stäbe gemacht hat und die haben auch was
ich richtig schön finde einen happy
family maßstab und zwar kann man da das
wachstum des kindes
ein tragen das heißt von geburt an und
die geschwisterkinder und kann so das
datum immer mit reinschreiben
das finde ich echt schön weil wir hatten
damals das weiß ich noch an der wand uns
immer so eingetragen oder am türrahmen
aber wenn man da mal um sieht dann kann
man das ja gar nicht mitnehmen und so
meterstab ist ganz praktisch kann man
einfach wieder zusammenklappen und
mitnehmen und auf der rückseite hier hat
man zum beispiel auch die
u-untersuchungen wann man eben zur
untersuchung gehen muss und so weiter
also finde ich echt voll schön vor allem
sehr praktisch ist auch eine tolle
geschenkidee und wir haben davon 500
stück zur verfügung gestellt bekommen
und wir machen das jetzt einfach so die
ersten 500 die bei uns online
das buch bestellen bekommen den
meterstab mit reingelegt und ja das
finde ich echt schön eine ganz tolle
aktion und ein paar hatten wir auch
schon auf der messe verteilt
mein name ist martin ich bin die anna
lena wir sind beim thema stabiler
unterstützen gerne das projekt aus das
sorgentelefon denn kinder sind unsere
zukunft
und die liebe regina pechmann sie ist
die geschäftsführerin von der firma hörz
die machen tumoren und sie hat 500
bücher bei uns gekauft schon vorab also
noch bevor das buch gedruckt war und
spendet die bücher jetzt an
kinderkliniken das finde ich richtig
toll weil vor allem dann die kinder dort
auch wirklich etwas davon haben
und dann hat sich auch meine liebe
freundin ihres mit eingebracht sie hat
das kit stilles lädchen in speyer und
ihre freundin monique hat uns melamin
geschirr zur verfügung gestellt und zwar
ich glaube drei oder vier riesen kartons
und die ihres hat jetzt die möglichkeit
einfach auch kinderhospize zu versuchen
natürlich nach absprache und dort mit
den kindern workshops zu machen um so
schöner etagen zu bauen und dass wir
nicht auch richtig toll und jetzt möchte
ich mich wirklich bei all den sponsoren
bedanken also wirklich bei fedrigoni
bürgertums bei stabiler bei frau käßmann
bei monique bei globus und auch bei
allen anderen sponsor jetzt hier nicht
erwähnt wurden und vielleicht noch im
nachhinein kommen werden
herzlichen dank für eure unterstützung
aber ich denke das buch ist ein richtig
tolles buch ich sage für mal ich mache
keine kaufaufforderungen aber das hier
ist einfach ein buch für einen guten
zweck für ein gutes projekt und
vielleicht fehlt noch die ein oder
andere geschenkidee für einen lieben
menschen und dann ist doch vom
kinderbuch wirklich was tolles hier
hinten im buch findet ihr übrigens den
songtext von dem lied kuchen voller
glück vom matti und das lied könnt ihr
euch übrigens kostenlos bei ihm
herunterladen
und ja wir hatten noch überlegt an
schönen clip dort so zu drehen
vielleicht schaffen wir das er noch ja
ich denke ich habe jetzt genug zum buch
gesagt wie gesagt das ist ein ganz
tolles projekt und ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr uns dabei unterstützt
vielleicht gibt es ja auch eine
einrichtung die ein paar hundert bücher
kaufen möchte und die zum beispiel auch
noch anderen guten zweck widmet das
kommt wirklich den kindern zu route und
die familien die sind wirklich sehr
dankbar
ich bedanke mich noch einmal ganz
herzlich einfach bei allen die uns
unterstützt haben bei allen die uns auf
der messe besucht haben
herzlichen dank auch an die messe
freiburg für die tolle organisation
sollen wirklich eine richtig tolle messe
und all meine besucher haben sich sehr
gefreut
ich freue mich schon auf die nächste
messe die wird dann in hannover sein
auf der infa dastehen aber auch die
daten alle auf meiner homepage und ja
vielen dank euch allen
das hat mir sehr viel spaß und freude
bereitet dieses buch auch zu produzieren
und ich wünsche euch viel spaß damit und
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal bis
dann liebe zuschauer
heute ist für mich ein ganz ganz
besonderen moment und zwar war gestern
das bowling spiel zwischen schavan und
der rest der welt und mit schavan hat
gewonnen
das ist schade das besondere das
besondere am schabbat ist dass schavan
ist der geborene looser hat noch nie in
seinem leben etwas gewonnen er hat in
seinem leben noch nie etwas erreicht
sogar seine eltern haben ihn versteckt
weil sie sich die ihnen geschämt haben
und ich hab mir gedacht habe du hast
diesen pokal verdient
der pokal ist genauso groß bei der
pastor seine ganze gelassen nein
und deswegen hat der sharan verdient
diesen pokal zu gewinnen
dass er auch mal in seinem leben
erfolgserlebnis hat ich gratuliere dir
von herzen
ja ich finde sagen eine ehre von einem
affen im pokal willkommen vor allem auch
noch von einem sprechenden affen sind
vielen dank
[Musik]
klasse
ja größtenteils ging es also auf der
messe natürlich auch kaffeemaschine
ernsthaft die hat adhs ernsthaft an den
frank ja und es lag mir natürlich sehr
viel dran noch mal ich warte kurz egal
was ich mache einfach auf hauptsache sie
klingeln nicht mehr
[Musik]